hello everybody welcome to part 12. i
think
my resident evil village gameplay where
um i did just have a bit that i didn't
record
um where i went back to the stronghold
and cleared two red areas that i had so
they're all blue
um making the entire map blue except for
that
one part that i just don't think we
really need to talk about
so this is how everything's looking
right now
we're doing okay uh i think i can
probably reload this
just swap that over and reload that on
both sides beautiful
doing all right um
it's weird to be coming back to the
village and not have anything to do
because i spent so long like making sure
i had done everything here but
it's all done pretty much so like i said
i feel like this got to be the end of
the game
unless i should go check out whatever
that image was referring to
with the phantom fish i can zoom in on
that i really feel like i already went
there but maybe i need to
maybe i need to go back i don't think so
in any case because
i already have all the recipes so
all right i have the final flask
of my child as is a normal thing to say
in any video game
and we're gonna put it
i think this is gonna be like a lift or
an elevator or something is my guess
hopefully we meet mother miranda wait
did we even meet heisenberg
oh we did earlier yeah what
hmm
find heisenberg okay
okay
i'm worried about having to fight him
because that dude
seems
way too strong for me
uh well where did you want me to go from
here fam just the whole way straight oh
yeah that's right the ceremony site was
empty when i first arrived
what's going on dope thanks for the
input ethan
great question what is going on
that's right we passed this like very
early on okay
well hello everyone i'm here i'm ready
to participate in the ceremony
i just carried that with me this fall
jesus christ
if you say so
[Music]
okay
a new area where is that gonna be
oh my oh down i go
okay i guess i live here now
all right great not claustrophobic at
all
lots of underground stuff going on here
i'd almost forgotten about that like
weird root tree thing
the [ __ ] was that all about
something to do with re7 okay
do you nothing i need to look here just
make it don't worry about the kid even
it'll be fine just get your ass across
the bridge
what a shitty villain don't worry about
the kid it'll be fine
[Laughter]
okay well
i don't love that i'm a bit worried
about this
all righty we're doing it is anything
glowing or anything anything to loot
anything
oh ethan winters
welcome thanks mate um but i actually
feel like i should be your therapist
but i suppose you survive worse back in
america
i like you thank you that's
this is some meat rose and miranda
i don't know miranda oh come on in don't
worry
i don't know her not a trap he's sort of
sexy
what are you planning so
you know that's
you just got a tank out here fam
all right um he's not like lady d
sexy but he is like
i don't know something he's got
something going on i'm just out here
just checking to see if there's anything
for me to pick up but
it seems a bit too broad that would be
mean of the video game to do that
i think i just feel like there should be
something
it's outside so i don't i can't tell
where'd you get these [ __ ] tanks dude
jesus there's actually a lot of money in
this
[ __ ] village um all right
oh there it is my my don't
mind if i do let's see if we can craft
no we cannot i don't want
any more mines okay
this is the vip treatment dude thank you
what was that
it was nothing okay anything
in here there is something in here for
sure
is it that it is can i craft now
still not quite to the extent that i
would like
okay what do we go this way this is
gonna be locked
i this way it is
okay how's this whole one fine
okay
okay okay okay
if i have to fight this dude i am
genuinely worried
because he's like a superhero compared
to the others man
and
i don't know
what you expect me to do
[Music]
what the hell mia
truth hurts don't
let me guess you're thinking take me out
like the others and then he gets to go
and save rose right
it's an interesting performance healing
my daughter it's unusual
look you got this all wrong
oh my god
is more elbow [ __ ] hole laura cause
that's what he sounded like
fish form
take a seat i don't know that i want to
do that right next to that oh then
listen ethan you're being played i
assumed
what are you talking about you think
this is a game
literally yeah pretty gloomy
lady super-sized [ __ ] you don't need to
talk about her that way
a psycho dog
well okay i mean don't you get it
it's a test to see if you're strong
enough to be a part of miranda's family
i don't know miranda
miranda's family neither did i but here
we are
and i'm next in line right kill me
move up the chain well [ __ ] that
i don't think i can tell you dude
personal issues
i just want to fix my daughter perfect
so do i
hmm do you have any idea how powerful a
kid is stop putting oz on the ends of
things
last time you freaked i swear to god
i don't love that
and we can use her to grind miranda into
pinks
uh if you stop saying miranda is not
like a weapon no i agree with him
ethan i disagree you're making the wrong
choice he's very strong and very cool
last chance yes ethan go with him you
don't want to find out what's in that
hole
heisenberg good i'll take my chances
oh jesus
oh it's fan man
classic resident evil villain fan man
rob if there are collectibles in here
thank god
okay still fine oh [ __ ]
okay okay okay cool let's go i disagree
that it's a dead end
damn it
fan man hates tubes so we should be fine
that'd be broken kneecaps for sure man i
say that as somebody who recently broke
the same knee twice
what was that thing fan man
you should know this dude come on he's
like one of marvel's most popular
um partly debated what he is he's an
antagonist or if he's like
you know some kind of anti-hero
like villain we're not really sure
because he's doing it all for his mom
part of the narrative is that he's um
he's like really soft at heart and it
really makes you feel like there's
a lot more to his story than you've
necessarily seen
[ __ ] i feel like i'm gonna miss
something in here please just let me
clear the room
thank you i would really like for this
room to just turn
blair here it is great
cool is he trying to get in here no
i'm i'm sick okay surely surely i'm not
in a timer in here
please please please please please baby
i just want a blue room you know i'm
saying
could be up higher but i'm so worried
it's gonna do the thing where i'm locked
out
of a [ __ ]
i wasn't knocked on my door it means my
food has been delivered
oh hello oh my what is you guys have
like vr headsets off
[Applause]
i don't think
that's two in the face okay thank you
why are you giving me so much money do i
just have more money
than i should i don't get it
please let this be it
yeah he's controlling that though
hmm
it's just moving is it just moving trash
one side of the other
i feel like that i would have liked the
extra detail there
but i get that that would be difficult
and needlessly expensive um okay
i still i'm actually pretty pissed at
you and on siding with heisenberg
but maybe he'll give us another
opportunity to because there is no
[ __ ] way we manage to kill the guy
who is
has superpowers
and he's just been kind of friendly and
again
he's sort of sexy so
i just feel like mistakes were made oh
my gosh this is messed up
oh i was going to say it pretty cool but
different strokes to different folks
this is like resident evil 2.
cool
how's this blue [ __ ] yeah
that is what i am about oh my friend my
good friend the duke
hello oh good i was just thinking of
ways to pass the tie
needlessly condescending but all right
not doing it didn't i pick up more than
that
but they're like did i not get the
others did i [ __ ] up did i make a
mistake again
it's fine i'm [ __ ] cashed up out here
what do i care take it
ah please let me know if you'd like to
strengthen your weapons
oh my oh my my my
my my my this is a lot
wow okay
yes
[Laughter]
it's a whole hundred thousand gone
a machine pistol or a semi-automatic
shotgun
ooh that's interesting
well i have some choices to make
huh okay so i think i'm just gonna go
all out
and sell my handgun
and the shotgun
we won't sell the rifle all that all
that
sell both of these and i guess it's time
to let go of the ladies lipstick just
because
things are expensive all of a sudden
sell all of that surprise you'd part
with this so early
it took a long time dude me too and then
we're going to buy
both of the new ones so we're going to
buy
the new shotgun and the new handgun
okay do i need
more room are you gonna come again i'm
all good
this thing's huge jesus um
okay are you down here
we'll just move you over here and then
we'll leave you
over here like this beautiful
um i can buy more space but i don't
need it yet but that seems suspicious
i feel like i should if it's giving it
to me right now you know
and i'm okay on ammo right now if i need
to i will buy that
but i could also go for upgrades
obviously
you know i don't even know what they
feel like yet so
i'm skilled at all sorts i'm gonna do
this
this stuff just yet that's fine
hmm how are we doing on
please come again it's all big now i was
like what the heck
who've been in my inventory who did just
do my inventory
i'll just move everything down here
we can actually put the knife up here
it's like a little it's nice i like the
little waterfall effect we've got going
with the weapons now
it's very pretty stupid
lockpick doesn't fit anywhere we will
put you
over here
i was editing these parts out when i
first started doing this but now
people seem to like the tetris
uh we will do this with you
and then move you all down here
um but we can also just move this one
over here
that looks fresh as [ __ ] my fan
and i'm gonna go how's the sniper right
now
i should probably crop sniper ammo
just in case
you know what i mean and then i'm gonna
shall i choose something for you no
you're okay
thank you king i'm gonna do just a
couple of these anyway
cool okay
whole bunch of new weapons shotgun goes
over here andrew goes at the top sniper
stays over there that's
how we like to have it laid out and i
put the pipe bomb at the bottom
okay
still not a ton of ammo for everything
but feeling good
really good
this should be an interesting adventure
um okay
e4 materials you say
is this where i'm supposed to go
is there another option down here
somewhere there's another white door
this way
there is interesting this is
quite an open area oh cool another one
of those okay
maybe i'm not as close to the end of the
game as i thought because i just like
expected the strongholds to
be the bulk of uh
of the last part of the game but we're
not gonna be able to do that until we
get that anyway
but maybe i was wrong maybe there is
more to it
uh with all the heisenberg situations
all right let's go through here
weirded out by the fact that i haven't
been able to save
oh i can craft something else too no i
can't every [ __ ] time i wanna
just just just one step at a time queen
sometimes you've got to call yourself
queen if nobody else is calling you
clean you know what i'm saying
all right somebody's upset out there
sounds like
i will thank you okay
you want me to you want me to knife that
are you sure
i'll try
okay if you say so my friends
how much better is this handgun
get away from me trying not to waste the
bullets to see how many will actually
kill them now
and i am wasting all of that hey
you don't get to do that
i keep putting too much pressure on
myself
i just need you to die
oh [ __ ] okay
that's gotta be that um
okay well didn't do great there
didn't mean a craft of mine keep doing
it by accident
[ __ ] sake i don't even know how i keep
doing it
um okay that's a lot of minds let's just
[ __ ] equip the mines man let's
shoot through these goddamn mines that i
keep [ __ ] crafting blasted
and i could pull the magnum back out no
i will equip you
my friend up to the top but for now
we will shotgun and we will go
who gave them the little vr headsets
that's what i want to know
this is honestly just the most resonant
evil [ __ ] environment i've ever seen
in my life
this is like re2 and re1 combined
jill been all up in this [ __ ] place
um
all right no i'm gonna go down first
okay
[Applause]
i love my friends
it's still two
and i was too far away that's a shame
yeah still two two shots i was hoping
that it might be
a good spoiler than that
i still just missed my miss my first
shotgun man
all right uh
it's not gonna let me interact with
whatever this thing is is the truth but
let's give it a shot just so i know the
situation
just have a quick look-see
that's what i thought okay
with my leg okay let's keep
going
hmm what are you making out here
heisenberg
he's clearly the strongest of all of
them right like i feel like he seems
like he is
oh my
hmm costing machine
oh is this going to explain why they
have these things that they wear
or if you just lobotomize them is that
what you're trying to tell me
wow [ __ ] hot so dude
find something fit in that depression
one day
um okay there's a lot going on here
i'm gonna have to like weld something is
what it's telling me
you know what why don't we just mine it
out
get more than one of them just one you
guys are right next to each other come
on
come on lance i got so many [ __ ]
yeah minds right feels good
i thought that that rope was another one
that i had left alive uh i could like
pick you
little fridge which you've got for me
yellow quartz indeed
don't mind if i do okay
oh god
so heisenberg's been creating these
people this is gonna be locked
um why though oh to defeat mother
miranda
surely
i would really like to not have to have
anything to do with you if i'd be
completely honest
um one fan man was enough you could just
stay dead
trying to assess the art
does he look like he stays dead
he actually does this looks like a still
that is not designed to be animated
unless there's a cinematic in which he
breaks out of it so maybe i'll be okay
how are we doing out here loads of [ __ ]
i'm missing apparently
all right mate i think you're gonna stay
still
not son please do
please do um okay
relief mold all right are you gonna move
now
[ __ ] help now
there it is they just wouldn't wanted me
to be in front of it because of the
thing on the foot you see
um all right
[Applause]
you are
but you see what i mean was uh because
it has a little foot thing that was up
i was safe from this side because it
would have been difficult for them to
animate its legs moving out on either
side
this is what uh working in the games
industry has done to my brain where
playing games is concerned
i'm like too aware of that kind of thing
it's like that would be really expensive
to animate
so it's either gonna be a cinematic
where they hit his legs or doing it from
behind because that way
i didn't have to watch his legs clip
through the front of that thing
um okay let's keep going i got the mold
for whatever the [ __ ] that other room is
basically what has happened
are the devices he's putting on all
their brains
um for like mind control or something
maybe
i'm wondering
we got oh did i go past it relief mold
and then is it gonna make what i need
for that
i watch a lot of people who forge stuff
it's one of my favorite kinds of like
youtube videos
it is seems useful fantastic content
okay so there's still something in this
room but i don't know if that's actually
true or
or if i just need to
finish the things i'm doing here i
imagine i'll be back in any case because
that door's not open
um okay take relief of a horse
my friend
thank you okay did that clear it
no i'll be back it's fine
[ __ ] better be
oh who's that then or is that just a
machine
just a machine okay
um this is probably going to be closed
but let's take a look
yeah i need some kind of cool key you're
not going to take that
you take any other kind of keys that
i've got my friend probably not we need
some kind of [ __ ] horse key
who knew heisenberg all about horses
not me
i really regret not starting an alliance
with him though i just
really wish we'd done that buddy
oh you're telling me he's gonna kill me
i see
fun times
okay
oh i can probably disable them i don't
know that i need to thought
i keep trying to get the shotgun to
spray to kill multiple people at once
but
i keep failing at it where did you
[ __ ] come from
all right that man just really left the
hub and his wake hang on hang on i got
worried about the noise i think he's
just over there
okay let's do that thank you
shotgun ammo
medicaid i crafted a [ __ ] mine again
i don't know how i keep doing it
[ __ ] sake okay
regrets dude stupid [ __ ] mind button
did i kill a man just there without even
knowing that i did it
i suppose i did all right
why does this one look especially
aggressive oh maybe the machine killed
him
hello my friends would you like a mine
because i have several
you can have one too oh no wait go by
come for it buddy your best friend
a mine thank you
okay
oh i got me [ __ ]
damn it uh [ __ ] i missed something in
here
okay so i found that there was some
explosive rounds sitting like right here
um and i got uh because i kept walking
back and forth several times i did get
hit by another part of the machine and
had to heal
so that's where i'm at okay
this little room has something in it
okay
beautiful all right let's go
that's a very pretty creepy hallway
all right this is locked
okay oh my god
this is reminding me of quake um what
the [ __ ] you've been up to in here
heisenberg you sick [ __ ]
sweet okay
um i need to go through back here anyway
though
check out what's going on
i don't think i can use a mind on this
we could use the handgun is it oh i'm
still on a handgun ammo
that seems wild
probably not gonna let me use a knife
but let's give it a try
didn't think so i'm gonna need to make
that explode i think
let's try sniper rifle
damn it it's gonna have to be a pipe
bomb
maybe i just don't want to waste
anything you know what i'm saying
i'll figure it out
where's the handgun ammo
backup generator let's not do that just
yet
let's have a look around first
okay maybe i should have done it doesn't
seem to be
too much going on in here what's this oh
just a regular way to open something
great cool cool cool
great okay
that's gonna open when i open
the other [ __ ] what's gonna be up there
i wonder
i really don't want to turn the power on
yet i'm concerned something is going to
happen
let's try a pipe bomb on this
even if it's wasteful just [ __ ] see
what happens
okay great
mechanical part cylinder
don't even know what i'd need a cylinder
for yet um okay that's always in there
though
so let's go
up the stairs before we touch the
generator which is just what i'm
assuming that i was supposed to do
is that another equal one because there
was a room there right
no no it'll be fine and i know we can
knife these so let's knife them
some knives on ya goodnight night
hey you let me [ __ ] know
dude [ __ ] this place uh
okay mechanical soldier sold that
a fully grown male corpse used a removed
heart and implanted cat out
muscle stimulation by electric shock was
successful
stimulation rather brain dead so no high
cognitive ability only moves by
destructive instinct then stops
yes no price the lower part of arm with
drill
need live bodies dude
destroy three likens in one minute who
is this oh no
it may stop functioning if the reactor
is destroyed okay appreciate that tip
i gotta hurt somebody right in their
reactor i suppose
cog mold
interesting i feel like the um unless
i've done it just in an unusual way
the way that this level is laid out is
different to normal and that i'm used to
seeing the things that i
like need
prior to um getting the items
i really [ __ ] that setting up sentence
up i'm used to seeing
the things that are locked or whatever
that's what i mean
prior to ah oh my god
that has been one of my worst jumpscares
this whole [ __ ] game
trying holy shoot his reactor okay it
did work it was a lot faster than the
other one
[ __ ] hell oh oh you explode upon
death
that's good to know you [ __ ] [ __ ]
jesus christ
uh was there a save thing here rob i
ain't saved in years
it has been years also did this
generator work
i never tried it i need something for it
okay
gosh
jesus christ um we're gonna mull
something cog mold that'll be it
great coalition of keys
that really [ __ ] me up jesus
how am i on things i am okay
on things
i might craft another one of these
because i like them
i just like them and we could do some of
that
we could do one of those actions too and
then we'll leave it
cool
it's gonna be a large cog
okay i'm still worried about what i
don't have in this room that one is
obviously the lock pick
that needs a heisman bugs key that's
right so i wonder if i have to make
heisenberg's key
this is going to turn on your power
yes i just made the cog
take it
great
such a disappointment why
i thought we could join forces against
that [ __ ]
miranda i would have liked that too
actually and i do have regrets
trying to aim for your [ __ ] chest
dude
okay
i didn't listen to anything that he just
said like my siblings
i want nothing more than to be free of
that [ __ ]
again i'm with you dude i really do
support so i need power
i need enough power i'm with you man i
she seems
she seems kind of [ __ ] i'm sorry that
ethan doesn't see it that way
these are the fruits of my power okay
well the strong will destroy the weak
that's the way the world
you should have never refused me ethan i
know i regret it
i already said that what a freak no
we agree with heisenberg ethan was i
scared of my own shadow justin
it's all right it was a time where i was
getting my own uh shotgun show
that's the best of us um
all right
oh whoa that was a bird cage sound
oh that bird cage is in here
that would be strange i feel like there
probably aren't
safe to assume that there are not um
no i oh there you are my friend hello
do that again look at him reacting
defensively
preserving yourself
so strong though do you like mines
because i have too many
would you like two of them maybe you
have two
that'd be
you neat great thank you
i'm supposed to do with all these
crystal hearts
i assume they're just sellable
okay
certainly feels like somebody's gonna
come for me in here
thank you do i have enough to craft no i
don't
okay more shotgun ammo would be nice
right now
just a hub it's all right
you want me to shoot that don't you i
really feel like you want me to shoot
that
um i just don't
really want to just yet but i respect
that you want me to
for sure
all right thank you don't mind if i do
should i just shoot it
oh my god what's happened to you my god
disgusting flashbang boom
sniper rifle hey
let's because we have ammo for it now
shortcut that boy and do that
see what happens maybe you don't want me
to shoot it you did
i'm not sure why you did
but i suspected that you would so
you know oh did i miss something in that
room
in here you tell me am miss someone here
where i miss
oh i [ __ ] miss
oh
okay great cool let's go
doing good doing oh is that on a timer
should i have
not done that maybe
there are two ways around here is that
what this is telling me
oh my god okay bud
[Applause]
oh that's done oh that's empty
okay hang on let me just pull my minds
back out because
i'm basically a mind pro at this point
oops take another one it's fine
we could maybe use that on him
you want to give this a shot you want to
come down here let's see
just just to see what happens i feel
like i had to shoot you and we'd be okay
but i kind of want to give this a try
see if you'll blow yourself up
buddy i'm over here buddy
spectacular that wasn't very efficient
but uh good to know good to know
okay really wish they would drop more
than just
money though nothing this way all right
just came from there do i have
everything up here
no my mind we've missed something and
it's that
okay cool good [ __ ]
all right lot of knife in to be had
um we're just gonna equip this and we're
gonna meticulously take this very strong
door out
very good locks you have heisenberg all
things considered your [ __ ] locksmith
a lot of things you doing right
that isn't one of them there's no way
i'm not gonna be attacked in here
no [ __ ] way
okay yeah that's what that's for i'm
gonna do this again oh
didn't have it equipped and now we're
almost out of mines
never would have thought i'd see it see
the day did i do that right shortcut
yeah i'm just gonna
mine it out again
oh he's just a little guy i probably
didn't even need to do that to him
he's just a little guy come this way
all right
okay
it's gonna be worse and i feel like i
probably [ __ ] that up but it's fine
we just take what we can
when it arrives
feels very weird to be walking around
with a sniper and uh clearly
close-quarters environment
but it has ammo so
of course i [ __ ] there's something in
here who am i kidding
because i can't immediately see it
doesn't mean it's not here somewhere
ah
more mines great very quickly is that it
no
could be counting upstairs though
possibly if i get through that
maybe up from the stairs okay
let's do that then
that case
this is counted as a different layer
i don't know let's investigate further
and then acknowledge that we may
potentially return oh my god
who the [ __ ] do you think you are [ __ ]
[Applause]
no he doesn't have a chest piece
all right mate oh is it on his back
i see no
still alive all right big boy i know
very very scary intimidating man
back and then face
and then face again and then you're
gonna explode
all right large crystal mechanical heart
it was in his back though
i'm not ready for that [ __ ] yet
thank you god bless is this where i
think that the downstairs bit was that i
needed to get to
no there was
[ __ ] something down there though
right
yeah hmm
um let me let me let me let me figure it
out let me figure it out okay i'll
figure it out give me a second
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
i kid you not
[Applause]
yeah i just died dude i'm so annoyed at
how long that took me to figure out
oh my god so i knew that i hadn't
cleared this
there was this yellow crystal or yellow
quartz up on the wall here that took me
forever to find i'm going to edit all
that out because it's basically silent
this took me like 20 [ __ ] minutes to
figure out how to open
jesus christ
it better be thank you oh my god
took my whole life okay jesus
okay well it's done
i was i was about to give up i was like
[ __ ] it it's fine we've already got that
one red room with the
shotgun shells or whatever it is that i
missed let's just keep going let's just
keep going through it who cares i
i hate life anyway personally i'm stoked
happy to have the magma though
some more mines let's just put the
magnum ammo
down here and
could do more explosive rounds i think
i'm just going to knock for now
oh yeah pull the knife out
wow hey
boom heisenberg's stupid maybe it's a
good idea
i don't partner with him since he
doesn't even know how to make a good
look oh we've gone full circle
oh my mind did i miss something in here
too
did i did i is it another
like glowy thing on a wall somewhere or
is it just going to be me interacting
with this
probably this ah
hello my man
okay is that it
i'm doing this to myself though you know
it's my own fault
i need to collect absolutely everything
is not resident evil's fault
not entirely at least it's certainly
involved being that
something new
now god damn it okay i have no idea
what's supposed to be in here
but i give up because i figure i have to
go back through there anyway because
that's where the labyrinth
puzzle was so go [ __ ] yourself you
stupid hallway
the amount of time that i've spent in
this game looking for one item in a room
is astronomical
uh that's gonna be there for me to kill
somebody
i missed out oh what the [ __ ] did i do
that
was the wrong [ __ ] gun oh my god
which way which way are you bro which
way where are you where oh god
okay not yet close
that should have done a fair amount of
damage i wouldn't think
so here being fine oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
i get that i'm not shooting your back
but
you made it sort of hard to aim for it
by
repeatedly facing me could you turn
around for a second my love
my handsome just handsome man just [ __ ]
it up
put another mine now oh am i out of
minds not so first
okay where'd you go
is that it yet
okay cool thanks bro appreciate that
where am i going aha
and then back oh am i wrong
i thought i was going through a door
here
i don't [ __ ] know what i'm doing
i don't [ __ ] know
i think i'm trying to get back to the
crafting room i've spent too much time
just looking for
basic objects that now i don't even know
where i'm [ __ ] at
oh my god okay that was an interesting
time
pause holy [ __ ] yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes
okay buddy okay fan man okay everybody's
favorite man the fan
hang on while i leave this room please
give me a second
real quick all right good day have a
good day
okay this is gonna be a boss fight out
here maybe
can i get back to the duke from here i
wonder
my hats
not sure that was the right
goal to make
yeah i don't know about all this fam
i think that i should pull the trigger
let's see what happens
i don't know why
oh i brought the juke to me welcome
oh that's interesting you're sure to
find something new
okay well then feel free to peruse thank
you my friend
i will sell that i will sell both of
those i will sell that six times
over apparently we'll sell those
we will not sell that
that's combinable
why don't we just take a look to see if
i haven't thank you for your patronage
nothing i have on me right now okay if
it's just
noted no we are going to sell all that
[ __ ]
i'm sorry for wasting your time bro but
i do have [ __ ] to sell
go dissatisfied i believe this is a fair
price
what's new what are you why are you
telling me you have new things what is
that that is new
for the shotgun firepower and rate of
fire
handgun greatly reduces recoil
i think maybe that one but why don't we
take a look at the upgrades live
it's a lot going on in here
i'm gonna do that these hands are more
dexterous than what and that oh i can't
afford that wow that's
[ __ ] expensive um okay then we'll do
we'll do [ __ ] which one
that oh excellent
choice i'm all right with it thank you
for your patronage
that works right i'm all right with it i
think that's okay
beautiful can we combine these stack
no um okay
so i do i want to go up right now
or the [ __ ] room dude
or do i want to do this
i don't know that that i should have but
that's
that is what i did
oh this is the first area but now does
this have something that i can do
something with
no that's right okay i will let me back
here though
which is uh where that area is that has
the thing that
yep okay
let's go back to v3
see i would have thought that i was on
the lower level and then he was
higher but i guess this is the lower
level
okay up here it is
got a long way to go fight fan
around here some [ __ ] way
probably bro probably
it's a bit scary it's all right he's in
we've done it
my gosh oh oh it has to be this way
stop calling her miranda no
she's long lost all her humanity he
doesn't seem like an [ __ ]
i must destroy her i'm with you on that
honestly
okay again give a [ __ ] about your family
drum
ethan okay i just feel like we should
have maybe
oh formed an alliance with this man
and i really regret that we did not
okay there's a lot going on here i think
this is probably the way to go
let's equip you at the bottom
even though i don't think i have any
ammo for you i don't everything's
getting [ __ ] low out here
no they still take two shots
oh boy i don't love that for me
it was a crawly sound i didn't like that
at all
uh [ __ ] you rusted scraps
damn it no okay
not yet not yet
somebody's making noises out here
somebody's being real noisy
it's just you it's too weird
move a fair bit
all right
oh you need another one oh that's just
your shoulder that's a waste
oh he did get back up [ __ ] hell man
oh lana getting careless bro
is there another one in here
we'll take the rusted scrap
and we will do that with it
and also um
i'm just going to take one of these
because i like them
and then that and a pipe
oh no we're all right we can leave the
rest of it
okay go okay all right great uh
this cave needs to have small things in
it
i love a lockpick there's more to be
found
okay lots of machinery in here for sure
oh they're mining the crystals maybe
is that what that was insinuating
interesting no there's something else
[ __ ] in here
i feel like this part of the game is
getting so
bloody specific up
i don't want to waste any of this [ __ ]
though [ __ ] hell
sniper it is
feels bad man that's it
all right let's go
where was that hole in the wall let's go
i don't know where i'm going but i know
that it is somewhere
professor mcconicle
i don't know what's wrong with me man
i've been in isolation for too long
all right go explode that money out all
right
let's do it then i got pipe bombs for a
couple of days
not like days but like a few days
oh my god i'm rich
let's get my [ __ ] shadow again dude
okay cool
okay great okay what the [ __ ] is this
this doesn't look safe mate this looks
maybe like a bad time like maybe
jesus okay if you say so
there's gonna be a boss fighting here
is that is what what you're alluding to
i don't love it
okay
i feel like this should actually be
really hurting even but um
he's fine he's got cam fluid
not a problem for him
uh we don't have a crop shotgun right
now still alone it's always more than i
think it is
okay cool well it's another [ __ ] red
room
maybe
that's what i was worried about another
one
yeah i was worried about that
um let's do
that and then let's pull this boy out
let me pause please thank you
and they can jump so they can jump where
did they jump to
they certainly can jump
oh [ __ ] oh my god what the [ __ ] is that
holy [ __ ]
my god you lot are on one oh
that's it okay great to be right then
just gotta take this dude out and we'll
be okay
and he's got to be close
didn't back that up as much as i should
have but it was okay
all right thank you
take that and that and
everything else that i possibly can
that's in this vicinity
this is correct okay thank you great
stuff
i don't buy that for a second i don't
buy that you have that little area right
there and you're not gonna give me
something for it
um all right
those weren't even fan man though so
this is gonna be a weird cut
but uh i was like in the bottom of that
fan room and i was like oh let me just
run back to the juke to save real quick
and then i couldn't help myself and it
was like what if i just checked that
red room one more time the good news
is that i did clear out that red room
which was
this one but now
i found more red rooms on this side of
the map because i realized that i hadn't
opened this door
and so i was like oh i should start
recording again
um it was courts of course it [ __ ]
was it was hiding in there probably
might be in this room too
i don't know anymore
because there's something here and then
i'm also um this is basically taking me
to a slightly new area
before we get to heisenberg's quarters
which i'm not gonna be able to get to
because i still need the key
um but there's one of these
[ __ ] gonna come to life i'm
sure of it
there it is oh he came through that way
huh
well that's not entirely what i expected
chest and again
and chest and head
and chest and head
and chest chest dead
man is not dead
now chest [ __ ]
please just die just die there
my god
still red he's [ __ ] so [ __ ] another
one of you gets up i swear to god
you're all cancelled everybody just
[ __ ] stay down
please medical log
revitalization surgery
hang on sorry give me a second mate i
just gotta i just gotta combine
some stuff you understand oh my god
no hang on get just one more second i'm
just going to move this down here maybe
i didn't
end up using the lockpick um
20 years old he fell down the well while
drunk
body is in good
arrested or oscar turns out
i just didn't notice that that opened
okay great okay let's go
okay um
i'm not positive i remember how to get
out of here you know okay
okay we are back at the duke who i'm
going to now give
some of this stuff that two of those
that that and that that's
craftable so let's do all of that
buy some stuff this is all an investment
ethan i agree
i do agree i'm gonna buy that one
looking forward to testing
yep and then can we afford anything else
anything worth round 30 we can afford
one of those on one of those
i'm gonna do the 20 000 reload speed
here
and then i'm actually going to save here
i don't even know how long this part's
going to be
i'm going to save right here and then
we'll go back for the fan
later let's see for your patronage
anytime so i will see you guys with pop
13. i really thought we'd be finishing
the game here
um but i'm sure we're on the final
stretch this is definitely more of a
labyrinth than i suspected and honestly
i think i've spent hours in this one
segment alone
looking for [ __ ] shiny stuff on
goddamn walls